so it's busy few weeks ahead very long
you looking forward to celebrating with
the Queen yes very much so
it's gonna be it's gonna be a fun sort
of Pat pink schedule lots of events
going on yeah I'm publicly and privately
celebrating as well yes yes
big big dinner I think probably on her
birthday as well yeah yeah keep it up
very late thank you so much for talking
to us and what does it mean for you to
be able to celebrate the 90th birthday
with the Queen it means an awful lot I
think um it's sort of really sinking in
now as we're so fast approaching it's
just how much of a major milestone is to
have the Queen celebrating a 90th and
after everything she's achieved and it's
it's quite a it's quite a moment for for
the family how important is family to
your grandmother it can't always have
been easy fitting in being monarch and
motherhood and how important is it for
her to get everybody around together
it's really important actually puts a
family so very much alongside her GT and
her role and it's what really makes her
tick you know shoot she works very hard
and she she sees service it's very
important but behind closed doors she
worries and and mines an awful lot about
the rest of the family and wants to make
sure everyone is happy and and sort of
you know finding their own path and
being a success
in terms of her birthday do you fight
over what you're going to get her as a
birthday present that's difficult
there's a lot of I mean what do you give
the Queen I mean that's just like the
hardest question over so we regular have
a lot of a lot of debate her and I
decided have a joint present this year
so it makes it a bit easier where we can
share the responsibility of getting it
right in terms of you growing up what
was it like to have the Queen as a
grandmother how hands-on was she when
she had the time to be I think when we
were very young obviously um it was it
was harder for her to have so much time
and we were always see living elsewhere
as well so we were never really all
together in the same place but whenever
we had the family moments and we met up
she'd be very keen on watching what the
children were up to and I think there
were moments when she loved the noise
and run around a house it kind of
brought the house to life and
it kind of made the real family
atmosphere alive but the rather moments
where I think she just was to smack us
over the head and tell the naughty noisy
children to go next door but no she's
always been she's always been incredibly
loving towards the children and I've
seen that now with Sharla and George you
know she's very doting on that on the
children and bless keeping our
particular Charlotte she's she's
fascinated by what shall I gets up to
well people talk about her having a
great sense of fun do you have any
particularly fond childhood memories
when he had a lot of fun with
grandmother
there was has been plenty of moments I
think the earliest one that I can
remember which two stuck in my mind for
a long time was Peter my cousin and I
were on a on a call bike in Balmoral and
we were chasing Zara around he was on a
go-kart and Zara or Peter and I managed
to heard Zara
into a lamppost and the lamppost came
down and it is goorsha
and i remember my grandmother being the
first person out of Balmoral running
across the lawn in her kilt and came
charging everybody was the most mighty
Bulacan and that sort of stuck in my
mind from that moment on that sir I
really should have been a be a little
bit more careful about what I'm doing
try not to kill my cousin's in terms of
horsepower obviously your grandmother is
very fond of going out riding you you
and your brother really enjoy your polo
now was it the queen who first got you
onto a horse it wasn't actually the
Queen the first time no she has
obviously been a huge source of
encouragement to us for riding I think
more than anything she would love us to
be more interested in racing her passion
for racing as everyone knows is it's
just second to bad-mouth she's she comes
completely alive and really relishes
every race you can get to but I think on
the on the sort of normal riding I think
my father was very keen for us to get on
a horse from a very young age so the
Queen has got Prince George onto a horse
quite yet
not just yet not just yet but she has
asked many times yeah she's trying he's
going on and looking at maybe more of
the formal side of royal life and I've
always wondered whether is there a sort
of in-house traineeship as it were does
she sit you down and talk to you from a
young age about what it means to carry
out royal engagements what you should be
doing things like walkabouts there must
be a real art to those the
I think waka bytes are completely chaos
they just give a meaning of their own
you just end up just walking in all
sorts different directions but it's
fantastic the people you meet from Orca
bites you it's sort of the sort of thing
you can never organize or plan it just
sort of spontaneously happens and you
you get to meet people you never thought
you'd need to all people who friend you
know friends or whatever and it's it's
um it's a very interesting dynamic but
no there's there's no there's no
apprenticeship sadly I'd be very nice if
there were sometimes but she's always on
hand to guide and to be there for
support and advice and you know she's
done she's done it all she's she's been
there done it and you know ninety odd
years pretty much so her source of
knowledge and wisdom is huge when you're
with the Queen carrying out engagements
what kind of reaction do you get from
both the general public but also world
leaders potentially they must kind of
the whole strata be in awe of her then
they melt around her and I've seen the
strongest men just literally sort of
become putty in their fingers they're
all they are well an or affair and
that's the thing I think that the longer
she's gone on for in her life and
service the more people have warmed her
more and she's now reached the ninety
milestone and I think there's there's
just so much love and admiration for her
around the world particularly with world
leaders actually who sometimes you can
imagine they're also revising for their
spot but with the Queen they see her in
a very different light talking about
world leaders for you now and your
brother and your wife you're taking on a
lot more of the foreign travel on behalf
of your grandmother and grandfather how
does it feel to be representing them
when you're going abroad is it a great
pressure does she talk to you a lot
about the countries you're going to
because she's been there she's done it
in most of these places no she hasn't I
mean she's been - I was trying to ask
the other day about how many countries
she actually hasn't been to there's an
easier question for adults than wherever
you been but no I think there's some I
think there's there's an element of a
little bit of pressure
you don't itself down but equally you
really don't let her down but like I
said she's always on hand for advice and
support and it's as much about us doing
it our way as it is about getting a
right and she's the first person to
support that sort of way she likes the
idea that we have our own style it's a
new generation and we there's no point
everyone doing it the same way is that
it's the evolution and the modernization
of the royal family and how it does it
stuff that actually is more interesting
and keeps it some keeps relevant but
with the more ceremonial side of things
surely there must be a formula to doing
it you're doing more and more
investitures presumably she must have
said right this is how you should be
doing it this is how long you speak to
people knighthoods for example the night
has very tricky rhetoric you cut years
off you're not careful but no I think
that when I first started investors I
was pretty terrified because it's a
let's say it's a formula it's very
strict and I did ask her for advice and
I had a run-through for my first
investiture because I really didn't want
to muck it up and cut some Lazare off it
would've been a little bit embarrassing
but after a while it kind of it just
developed its own and it's it's so
important that you listen and give as
much attention as you can teach
individual there's a lot of people come
through and when you hear their stories
you won't talk to them for about an hour
but you only get about two minutes with
each person if that so it's quite say um
it's a tricky process to try and make
sure that you get to give people as much
time as you possibly can because I've
met some of us amazing people from
investors and it's incredible to
actually see rather country what goes on
and there are so many wonderful people
doing incredible voluntary work foster
carers or whatever it might be there's
some fantastic stories how supportive
has the Queen been in terms of you
trying to balance at the moment royal
duties and your job as an air ambulance
pilot lots of people have their own
views about how you're balancing that
but what does she think she's um
surprisingly she's very supportive very
enjoy the moment she understands that
I'm a fan
man and I want to be around for my
children as much as I can
she understands that I you know whilst
we've got three very active generations
of the family she's very much at the
helm the Queen and she's you know
incredibly active her schedules packed
my father is very active charitably and
otherwise and and there's me and Harry
and Kathryn and Evan else so it's kind
of there's a time and a place for and
you know taking on more more
responsibilities and that will come and
and I look forward to doing that but the
moment I'm very much cost rating on my
family you know so in the community with
the Aramis which is incredibly
worthwhile meaningful job that I loved
working on-site and best doctors in the
country and also seven the Queen as when
she requires me to so yeah it's a it's a
it's a good balance and she's she's very
supportive that she's backing you up
what what does she meant for you as a as
a female influence in your life
especially during your teenagers um I
think she's been she's been a very
strong female influence and having lost
my mother at a very young age it's been
taking important for me that I've had
somebody like the Queen took up to and
who's been there he's understood some of
the more complex issues that you know
when you lose a loved one can compare so
no she's been incredibly supportive and
I've really appreciated her guidance if
we look back at when your grandmother
became Queen she was only 25 she's
learnt over all those decades she has
learned so much do you talk to her about
what it's like to be sovereign and what
that may mean for you in the future I
haven't yet but I probably should it's a
I remember very much with my great
grandmother actually the Queen Mother
that a lot of my friends at the time was
saying you must speak to your
great-grandmother by it's what it was
like in the war and you know her
experiences because it is very important
that the younger generations fully
understand quite what the other
generations lived through and gain as
much experience and knowledge of them as
you can and I haven't breached that
particular subject with her just yet but
ever
thing else around work life and visions
and objectives I do very much talk to
about and she's very young they said
she's very supportive and very willing
to talk about it
everyone will be obviously celebrating
her 90th birthday we are so used to
seeing those big celebrations you all
coming out onto the balcony at
Buckingham Palace that sea of people in
front of you on the mail do you ever get
used to that in terms of appreciating
just what the Queen means to the country
and the Commonwealth I think it's some
it's quite quite surreal moment every
time and it must be more surreal for
fara watching as well but some it's a
it's quite a it's become a very iconic
moments having the whole family on the
balcony and it's um it's something that
I never really appreciated it growing up
I mean only now do you start to sort of
see the pictures in the history and all
sort of important to it but I think it's
a it's a unifying moment and that's what
the Queen does she's a she's a huge
symbol for unification and I think it's
it's a real focal point having the
balcony and the Mao and everything like
that some you know the front of backing
Palace is one of the most famous
buildings in the world so to have the
Queen and her family back in Palace
there it's a very very symbolic moment
and if they're singing happy birthday
will you all be joining it we'll try and
get it in time as quite a delay between
the cries and us but yes I'm sure
there'll be a happy birthday moment on
the lines
Prince William thank you so much for
talking to us and enjoy the celebrations
Doreen thank you